it took 20 minutes before Jughead
noticed that his hot tub had sprung a
leak once he realized it he opened the
hot tubs drain and the rest of the water
rushed out in 40 minutes the rate at
which the water drained from the hot tub
in gallons per minute is shown how many
gallons of water were in the hot tub
before it started to leak so let's see
what they have over here so they've
plotted time or they probably gallons
per minute versus time within minutes
and so we see here this blue line this
is the rate at which water drained from
the tub rate which water drained from
the hot tub so at minute zero the water
wasn't really draining from the hot tub
and then more not just more drained but
the rate at which the water was trading
increased so ten minutes into his bath
it was the the water was draining at a
gallon per minute and the 20 minutes
into his bath water was great draining
at two gallons per minute and then he
noticed it and he opens the drain I
guess he wants to accelerate the end of
his bath so he opens the drain and then
all of a sudden water starts draining
out at a much higher rate at 20 gallons
per minute but then that decreases and
so we could think about physically why
why that might decrease maybe there was
just a it was just less pressure or
whatever we're not gonna go into the
physics of it but we're just going to
take this chart as fact but the rate at
which the water drains decreases all the
way to the 60th minute which is 40
minutes after he opened the drain 60th
minute all of the water was drained all
of the water was actually drained out so
given that how do we think about how
many gallons of water were in the hot
tub before it started to leak and I
encourage you to pause the video and try
to see if you could figure it out
yourself before I work through it well
to answer this question how many gallons
of water in the hot tub before it
started to leak that's this answering
the same question as how much total hot
water drained out so how much how much
drained drained out and to think about
that we can just kind of go back to what
we knew before we learned about calculus
if I have something happening at a fixed
rate so let's say that this is let's say
this is gallons per minute
so this is still the same the same the
same context I guess you say this is
time in minutes now let's say things are
draining out at a constant at a constant
rate if you wanted to figure out how
much drains out over a certain interval
of time let's say this interval of time
right over here let's call that delta T
over delta T you would just multiply you
would just multiply the rate over that
interval of time the rate over that
interval of time which would be the
which would be which we could represent
by this orange height right over here
times the amount of time that passed by
which essentially would give you the
which would give you the area under the
curve over that interval the area under
the curve over that interval this this
area would tell you the gallons that
drained over that delta T and this
doesn't just apply when you have a
constant when you have a constant rate
if your rate look something like this as
we've seen in other videos as we've seen
in other videos you could figure out the
amount the amount that has drained the
amount that has drained in a specific
interval let's say this interval right
over here by x essentially figuring out
the area under the curve over that over
that interval and the units work out if
you multiply gallons per minute times
minute your this area is going to be in
terms of in terms of gallons this area
is going to be in terms in terms of
gallons another way you could think
about it and this goes back to well how
do you figure out the area of a
trapezoid right over here well the area
of a trapezoid you could find the
average height of the trapezoid which
would be the average of the the
beginning and the end period you take
that average over there and this is this
would work for a line like this if you
take that average height and multiply by
by the change in time you are going to
actually you're going to figure out you
are going to figure out that area and
that's another way of thinking another
way of thinking about it is you're
taking the average rate over that
interval
is the interval and that's going to give
you the total number of gallons and so
we just have to apply that idea over
here we just literally figure out the
area under the curve over the entire
interval when the water was actually
leaking or draining so essentially the
area under the curve between zero
minutes and 60 minutes and so it's going
to be this area all right so that in
magenta plus all of this area under
under this part as well and to help us
think about that I'm just going to split
that up into some sections so I have
this triangular section up here so I
have this triangular section I could
just think about this as a trapezoid but
I'm just gonna split it up into a
triangle and a rectangle and then I have
and then I have this section right over
here in green so what is the area of
this entire thing well the area right
over here we have 20 gallons per minute
so 20 or sorry not 20 gallons per hour
20 minutes 20 minutes times 2 gallons
per minute 2 gallons per minute times
1/2 times 1/2 gives us the area under
this triangle so that's going to be that
is going to be 20 20 gallons we see that
the units work out nicely and so that's
essentially how much this drained out in
the first 20 minutes and then this green
area is going to be 40 minutes 40
minutes times 10 gallons per minute
times 10 and actually maybe you know the
unit's since I'm breaking it up in this
strange way I'll just multiply I'll just
figure out this this area in a unitless
way so 40 times 10 which is equal to 400
and then finally in blue I have 40 times
this height right over here between 10
and 20 is another 10 but I'm going to
multiply that times 1/2 so it's going to
be 40 times 10 times 1/2 which is going
to be 200 and so you add all of these
together these areas together you're
going to get 400 plus 200 is 600 plus 20
you're going to have six hundred and
twenty gallons 620 gallons
gallons is how much water and total
drained out or how much water was in the
tub before it started to leak or the hot
tub that this is quite big for a regular
tub but this could be like immunological
you're a hot tub or something